[Music]
you know what I love is the creative
ways that you guys kill zombies it seems
like you're they're always coming up
with new and more creative ways for you
to take out and in the beginning it was
just shot to the head or hit and then
it's getting more and more they're using
all kinds of crazy appliances and they
challenge each other you know they're
challenging themselves all the time I
mean but for me you know I mean you
never forget your first you know so from
here was the first guy ever on the first
kill I ever had and he was a helicopter
pilot he's lost his legs and and the
poor guy was lying in this field there
means quite hot down in Georgia covered
in ants and you know at one point I
leaned down someone said you okay me
said I love it that's the show I mean
you know they really love and those guys
who come in and play the zombies and
they're in makeup from 4:00 in the
morning till you know very late at night
their commitment is total it's fantastic
and it makes our job easier so you know
if you've got fifteen guys as zombies
coming at you and they're totally
committed you know there's not a lot of
acting going on you just got to get out
of there yeah I would think that it
would be easy to act afraid if the
zombies were that gray and then some of
them come back again and again and you
know they really challenge themselves
and they're great guys well you talked
about Georgia
we traveled this show to Atlanta last
spring and actually the weather hadn't
gotten really hot yet but I've been
there in the summer and it is
unbelievably hot what's it like well
it's the humidity the humidity gets you
I mean it's hovered in fake blood I mean
there's fake blood everywhere but again
you know Weatherly where the actors on
this show I mean the crew were there
24/7 I lose weed least to go back to our
trailers and get a bit of air
conditioning sometimes and the guys who
play the zombies they're there all the
time and they've got real horrible blood
on them and they got all the Flies on
them in the ants but I think it adds to
the show you know the show is about
people you know really up against it and
in this terrible world so we're not
going back and forward I mean you know
the show for me is ruined madmen for me
I actually love watching Mad Men but now
watch it I think there you are in your
condition studios and your nice suit
drinking that's why I think how can you
pick your check up at the end of the
week
[Laughter]
yeah you do yeah it's always like yeah
well you know I've talked to so many of
your cast you guys lose weight over the
course of the season and you can it
actually adds to a lot to the realism of
the show because you look like people
that are starving and fighting for
survival because you really are yeah
we're going I mean I think the heat
really does add to it so you know when
you see that sweat and nobody's there
going is my hair all right everybody's
going for it and you know and as I say
for us as the actors it's one thing but
for the crew I mean they really go
through it and they're they they're a
fantastic crew second to none I love
them with them would you do you want to
be a zombie would you like to be as I'm
sure you know if you're a zombie if you
ever see the makeup team sort of doing
the plaster of Paris ready for your
zombie makeup then you're really running
out of there well I don't want to be any
ever be a zombie I love being on the
show and I love being the governor well
you know that's the other thing too is
you're living with that every week you
get the script no we don't know you can
you flip you immediately fail the end
give it an actor's read you know which
is just read your own bit and we look
and see if we're still little still
alive at the end of it and then we can
relax if we are and we all go into our
trailer and we we read the script and
then you know suddenly sometimes you
come out this one door still closed and
it's someone who's not gonna hasn't made
it you know it's always tough it's the
act of finding out everything else crap
on that day yeah finding out on that day
and week so I like the fact that it's a
show that kills off its act as though
you know kills off its leading man it's
not like a Star Trek show where you know
you've got four guys beaming down and
there's one guy you've never seen before
and you think he's not making it back to
the ends of life you always know that
you always know he's always got a red
he's always brand-new and he's like
yeah so we don't have that you know no
one's safe on our show and I think
that's the way we're like yeah